here are some exclusive gameplay from
the pre-alpha build of hot wheels
unleashed
coming from developer milestone after
spending four hours with the game
i could say that it hit that arcade
style racing niche pretty well and it
was a blast to play
it also does have a bit of a skill
ceiling when it comes to understanding
different drift strengths depending on
the angle of the road
boost management and use of precise
throttle control i
don't think my sonoma or thunder hill
track experience helped me much here but
it was definitely cool to see some
childhood toys of mine come to life
in this video we raced through three
tracks spider trial
speed vault and dragon's den but the
final game will plan to have 40
different tracks and 60 plus different
hot wheels
this is a pre-alpha build so you may see
some bugs and balancing issues
if you're a fan of racing games then let
us know in the comments below and
subscribe to gamespot
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you